regardless if you're trying to raise
money for a non-profit if you're trying
to run for mayor if you're trying to
sell socks or change the perception of a
brand regardless of what you're all
doing here all of us are trading
attention all right I'm gonna start
first of all I want to thank everybody
for coming out it's great to see a bunch
of familiar faces and a bunch of new
faces the format here is I'm gonna maybe
kick it off for 10 or 15 minutes maybe a
little kind of how I see things and and
then I'm gonna have an incredible
individual join me to interview a little
fireside chat and a lot of her introduce
yourself in a little bit and that will
go for what 15 20 minutes you think yeah
I mean ultimately if you have any
context for me I'm obsessed with as much
QA as possible and so I think that's you
know I'm just appreciative of your time
and I'm sure there's many things you
could be doing tonight and so for you to
come out it means a lot to me obviously
for me personally this is a fun night as
I watch Vayner as a whole gained
momentum in this incredible city in this
part of the world it's exciting to me
you know we're now a couple of years in
are we readers in Eric or - what are we
three years into London now - okay cool
we're uh yeah as we're uh you know we're
starting to make some noise here and I
and for me I just really enjoy this
market quite a bit I'm excited to slip
out here every six weeks or so maybe
going forward as this continues to grow
and more importantly the both on the
corporate side and the entrepreneurial
side there's just a lot of great energy
and a lot of opportunity in the
marketplace and a lot of the stuff that
I feel as you guys probably know is very
us centric by nature but what's great
about a market like the UK or most of
Europe for that matter outside of Russia
is that a lot of things around influence
or marketing or voice Facebook or many
other things that I'm passionate about
actually are even a better deal in this
market because of the supply and demand
of how many people are doing it and how
far
along the mark it is and so I've always
found it kind of interesting and fun
that a lot of the stuff that I'm most
passionate about
actually over indexes outside of the
market outside of mainland China and and
Russia specifically because they are
built on the back of the googles and
Facebooks and instagrams of the world so
uh all right so where do I want to start
i I think you know when I speak I try to
bring as much value for the net audience
and I think the biggest thing that I'd
like to share first is I'm fascinated by
people's inability to understand how
much abundance and opportunity there is
in the system regardless of what anybody
is doing here and I've got a good sense
of the most corporate of corporate to
the most entrepreneurial of
entrepreneurial starting off you know
it's you know I think it's really fun
for me when I watch mainstream media or
society decide to paint one narrative
completely at the face of reality aka
this is the greatest moment to be alive
there's more opportunity there's more
advancements no [ __ ] there's a billion
things wrong there always will be it's
how we're wired but for me at its top
line framework what continues to keep me
up at night in a good way is my god
there's so much opportunity this
internet thing is a lot bigger than I
think all of us are really settling into
including people that try to spend all
their time figuring it out like me and
so first and foremost I really want to
talk tonight in a macro about offense
you know there's so much abundance
there's nobody there's not a company or
person on earth that success is coming
out of your pocket and so once you
actually understand that truth you spend
very little time on defense and worrying
about anybody else and you start
spending all your time on the one thing
everyone in here should be spending
their time on regardless if you're
trying to raise money for a non-profit
if you're trying to run for mayor if
you're trying to sell socks or change
the perception of a brand regardless of
what you're all doing here all of us are
trading attention
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I think that's one way to get attention
that was very well played sound is
definitely audio is something I make its
attention and an attention is
underpriced if you know where to look
for it and it's it's just a remarkable
time for all of us there's so much you
can do and I love that the internet gets
to be the middle not a person you have
to understand why so much is happening
socially in our society the
establishment has lost control the
Internet is the middleman of information
the end and so now what's happening is
we have to face all our shortcomings
around race and sexism and nationalism
and all the things we will do but I
think in a hundred year window this is
gonna be the greatest thing because once
we start understanding each other a hell
of a lot better and once the Mattocks
like empathy and compassion actually
become differentiators for your own
selfish wants and needs we will all be
forced into a far better place because
the old way of media and communicating
allowed for shadows which created all
these shortcomings so everybody can sit
here and tell me everything they're
worried about socially or business-wise
and I will tell you you should be
optimistic because these are the
beginning stages of a far better place
for all of us now the question becomes
what are your selfish needs over the
next decade that make you upset about
the current state of things and that's
what you have to realize if I could you
know we can go into I'm sure because I
know how good she is we'll get into
details around digital trends and I
can't wait wherever you want to go with
QA I'm thrilled you have to understand
the game you're playing and the game
you're playing is number one this
outside of diseases and terrible
accidents everybody here is gonna live a
fuckload longer than they think if you
look at the macro developments it's just
scary you just are and so all of a
sudden when I look around this room what
breaks my heart is that 42 year olds
don't realize that it's early I don't
know what else to say I it's a
heartbreaking thing for me to know that
88% of them are going
live another 50 years and they've
basically decided that they missed their
chance that's completely not practical
and it's buying into propaganda no
different that I'll use something that's
in society I think terrorism is a super
fascinating thing if it was real a car
the size of a truck would run into
people in London Paris New York every
day of the week because it's 100%
unstoppable the fear of it is far
greater than its reality and so I think
about age that way you live in a world
now where there's so much extreme
success for the youth that a lot of us
who are over 40 didn't grow up with if
you couldn't get that big and win that
well because the internet didn't exist
and you had to go through the incumbents
to get there so what happens is you look
at a 27 year old that seemingly has
their [ __ ] together or winning and as a
42 year old you might say [ __ ] I [ __ ]
up meanwhile you have your whole life in
front of you and so I am unbelievably
I'm unbelievably moved by things in a in
a sad way like the Kate Spade news right
yesterday right like I'm really into
like the mental thing and like this is
the operating system and so you know
probably some of you are aware of this
for a long long time a lot of the
motivational part of me was something I
wasn't willing to express in public
right I didn't want to be I still don't
want to be a motivational speaker I have
no interest in that whatsoever I really
don't I recognize I have motivational
tendencies and it's because I'm
optimistic
I'm not motivational I'm just optimistic
because the math and data is in my favor
we're healthier we're better there's
less bad it we've got eyes on bad and we
should cuz that's how you smoke out bad
I'm thrilled I think it's the best right
now and no matter what your selfish
wants and needs are as a person you've
never had a better chance to make it
happen than right now your grandparents
had [ __ ] compared to this I love when
everybody runs all these articles right
now about like Millennials have it worse
than a generation before sure if you
decided to collect $200,000 in debt in
college and go work in a corporation I
understand
but theoretically that's not the truth
that is your circumstance that's the
data because everybody was taught to be
a student and go
playing the system it doesn't mean that
it has never been more practical for you
to get out of that context and do your
thing in the abundance of opportunity
you may have been trained grew up in a
household been so marketed to to believe
this is the only way you can go but the
second you're willing to look and see
this you know you know what I think
about you know that picture where they
have that thing where like you look at
it you're supposed to say is it two
people kissing or a glass of champagne
that's you don't want to talk about
right you guys have seen that [ __ ] right
I don't know what the [ __ ] that's called
but I gotta figure it out for the
purpose of my analogy it's basically how
I think I live life I just think
everybody sees it one way and for from
for whatever reason parenting
circumstance DNA I've always seen it the
other way and it's never been more
crystal clear for me than it is right
now which is it is a ridiculous
opportunity out there and I highly
recommend you get yours and when I say
that look I don't I actually as a
counteract to the energy you might think
I'm putting out I think most people
aren't entrepreneurs I think one of the
great mistakes that are happening in our
society right now is everybody wants to
be an entrepreneur because it's not a
pedestal now like I don't know it's
crazy to me to watch like rappers and
athletes all think I'm cool because they
want to be on like entrepreneurs having
its moment the problem is that's a
talent like if you do not have the
stomach for wearing scarlet letters you
will lose and so this is not about go be
an entrepreneur or dream or [ __ ] the
secret dream it will be true this is
practical [ __ ] this is if you actually
understand what makes you tick which
could be being a number six that a
company that you believe in which could
be a million different things if you can
deploy self-awareness and you deploy
effort against that self-awareness I
promise you the history books will say
that the US during this time had the
most opportunity because the fundamental
society is being shifted on the back of
this technology and that's without
anticipating what blockchain is actually
going to do and many other things that
are happening so I guess we're opening
rant is I'm optimistic as [ __ ] I hope
you are as to
and if you're not you need to really
start asking yourself what's going on
because if you're not winning in
happiness right now then you've got a
real problem because this last 10 years
of global economic growth won't last
forever and all this abundance will
shrink and if you don't grab your land
now they'll be less to grab when we have
to pay the piper for all the [ __ ]
other people are doing and so I really
really encourage you to think about
yourself in a much longer term and a
much more self-aware and I just
genuinely believe a lot of good will
come of that and that I wish you way
more than all the stuff that I'm excited
to talk about which is the micro of
execution within these platforms that
create this macro thesis so thanks for
being here once you introduce yourself
I'm Gary you know I've actually had some
chats and for my coverage of masters was
about topics like voice AI which is
something we can get into if you'd like
if you'd like there's nothing other
areas want to get into that and and
you've actually picked up on something
that's been on my mind and on the
Mashable team's mind a lot recently
which is this idea of compassionate
technology and empathy and I noticed
like and your Instagram feed and all the
quotes you use use the words kindness
and caring and compassion and it seems
to me that there's been something
recognized along the way very very
recently amongst the large tech
companies about their responsibility
towards fostering a more compassionate
use of technology if you look at Apple
for example and they're devising ways to
wake make their iPhone less addictive
Instagram looking at ways in which they
can
users can monitor the amount of time
they spend scrolling ie
potentially wasting time so I'd actually
love your tape on this issue because
sometimes I feel like you give mixed
messages about technology I hope you
don't mind me saying that hi Irene I
think please good because you're very
much technology yes right but there are
clearly negative side effects too - as
well so how do you address those
negative side effects those negative
emotions that people feel when they're
on Instagram and they feel the toxicity
of the platform how do you make you
manage to make it work for yourself what
can you teach others well I think I
think that's a fair observation because
I would I would argue that my strength
is in my contradictions and being able
to hold different views at the same time
I also think that in our interactions
with each other you and others are
taking too far of a pessimistic view and
were fear-mongering technology a little
bit too much on this thesis my question
is what's the alternative to me we
cannot have a conversation of addiction
of an Instagram feed without asking the
question those three and a half hours
that Susan in Manchester is spending in
the feed that we are so critiquing over
here on our pedestals what was she doing
with those three and a half hours
otherwise I think we've long forgotten
about what's the ROI
of a girl in her room on her own phone
line talking to her three friends for
six and a half hours I think we've long
forgot about in those same three and a
half hours I love how people think going
through Vogue and going through a
magazine and Sports Illustrated for
three hours in an afternoon over a cup
of coffee while it's raining is any
different than the exact same thing that
you're doing on Instagram which is
images on a piece of paper so couple
things number one yes and that's why I
love recording everything because some
of these things will play out net-net do
I believe the addictions to phones open
platforms social networks all these
things that have become the foundation
of communication in our society do I
believe that that is better
then allowing Rupert Murdoch read
Summerson and four other men in their
70s to control all the thoughts we think
through media and their editing yes I do
do I think that sexism and racism and a
lot of other human shortcomings are a
product of us that system sure do so if
you ask me about the alternative of
Instagram and the iPhone and Facebook
versus CBS and the BBC and sky and the
London Times
I will choose what we have now is
because for example the type of hormones
you release from your brain the dopamine
levels you get on those bikes the
cortisol levels when you see the red
notification pop up yes screen so
there's something happening here to our
shows there's engagement happening with
a certain community it wasn't happening
when you're just watching a TV screen or
if you're just flicking through a book
you've got this whole other world be
careful be careful you're making an
assumption that people aren't speaking -
they are happening yes but if you look
at the biggest habits we're not talking
back to a lot of those things either
right like you're making an assumption
that we are leaving well here's the
question do I rather have the masses be
the ones that [ __ ] with your psychology
or do I want to leave that to your
mother and your aunt and your coworker
I'm being serious here guys look I think
about the [ __ ] a lot I think we're
having very lazy conversations and
defaulting into what we always do in the
same way that big companies screw a
knife in Google but except television
commercials
I think we're accepting that these
devices are doing something without
recognizing do I think it's better for a
lot of people in this room to consume my
content over the pessimistic content
that their mother would be giving them
over the phone if this didn't exist yes
I do
okay sure twenty
5th of may we brought in new data
protection rules
gdpr here in Europe I've heard which
leads me to ask you a question about
regulation yes like broadcasters are
regulated here in a we have off
complicated virtualizing status
associations and the internet in many
ways feels like a Wild West which
provides so much opportunity that
opportunity to talk about but it also it
imposes the question about how much
regulation is needed and I wonder what
your thoughts are on whether something
like gdpr is needed in the US well look
I think it's a good question my natural
reaction is of course Europe did
over-regulation right I think it's been
the great shortcoming of Europe as a
whole and I think the US will follow
suit because every leader in the free
world always starts to get soft over
time in a lot of ways correctly and a
lot of ways not correctly I think it
will happen in the US because I think
the income in companies like Facebook
and Google will realize that's an
advantage to them not a disadvantage so
they will work with Congress to get
these rules because it will make the
incumbents of progress have a much
harder time to capitalize look I believe
I forget about free market this is not
about being a capitalist or things of
that nature i Gary believe the number
one underrated thing in the universe is
the human being I am flabbergasted by
our inability to understand how special
we are this was back to the point I made
about terrorism because if we were had
so many bad people that would happen I
want to remind everybody that the free
world could be blown up at any moment
now for the last 70 years we are
unbelievably as an animal good like
unbelievably it's just the truth and so
I think we get very fancy and sit in
ivory towers that 87 people think that
they should be regulating us on
everything at all times that I think at
times it gets heavy-handed I think the
human is very good at regulating him or
herself but at the same token I'm super
not overly emotional like if we're
talking about like free markets versus
not I'm not devastated by it to me
if everyone's playing by the same rules
almost every game is interesting to me
as long as everyone's playing by the
same rules
I think people play by the same rules
when it's open not when it's closed and
I think that um I think it's probably at
some level a version of it inevitable in
the US because it actually helps the
incumbent big companies not the end user
bu and race and there are some very very
credible voices out there that believe
these things you and all you touched on
this before in our conversations what's
your viewpoint on that now yeah I think
I think there's a really logical path to
the robots killing us I mean it like I
don't know if we were a bunch of [ __ ]
dinosaurs sitting around one day we
would have laughed at the humans winning
this game too I mean is it so
far-fetched I don't think so I think
we're starting to see [ __ ] I'll tell you
that robot that isn't gonna be able to
be detected by blu-ray that [ __ ] scared
me I'm like that makes sense
like I I don't know I try to stay in my
lane a lot of the stuff I'll talk about
tonight I'm I know my [ __ ] I feel
compassionate I'm fully guessing here
now but I will definitely say I'm
definitely not willing to say no chance
never okay all right next all right
stuff that you really do and Facebook
Instagram snapchat Twitter all the
social platforms right yes everyone
wants to know myself included as part of
a publisher is how would you use this as
a key marketing tool or a key tool to
reach an audience and there's so many
changes going on now with Facebook in
particular all of the various different
controversies that come up with
dating crisis yep the algorithm changing
the control they have all of that stuff
there's a major power story going on I'd
love to know your thoughts on where it's
where it's at where should people be
focusing their energies on or is it a
case of like trying to have a little
finger in every little pie the way thing
about this is very simple I think that
the Internet is the first layer of our
society period and then I think there's
been seven to ten companies globally
that have been able to get so big there
and layer themselves on top of that
layer a tollbooth for say a facebook an
apple a ten-cent right and then it's our
jobs whether it's Mashable or Gary Vee
to be the best next layer by using the
layer that was built on top of the
internet layer 2x I think how do I [ __ ]
Facebook before it [ __ ] me right that's
how I think and I think what publishers
did extremely poorly in the last half
decade is they loved what Facebook was
doing for them in the short term and
they gave up all their equity and they
got and let's call it what it is awfully
lazy and complacent and allowed Facebook
and other platforms to get the equity
from them because they didn't reinforce
their email they didn't reinforce their
first party data they didn't reinforce
their things so I think you have two
camps you have the camps that are like
[ __ ] social it's this terrible enemy and
I'm all about first party data and I
have an email service and text message
and I'm [ __ ] more old-school Quandt
you know dr Gaillard dude from the
2003-4
era [ __ ] all this world right and then
you have a different regime that's like
loves all this stuff I kind of sit back
to your point in both I love having
first in line and having that data
I love having an email list I love
having a website but I also love
dominating on Facebook and LinkedIn and
snapchat and Instagram because that's
where the attention is right and anybody
that creates friction for the user is
doing it at giving up some of the value
at the same token you need to create
some of that friction because if you let
everything play out on that platform you
become commoditized Facebook is the
number one underpriced platform in our
society Facebook and Instagram together
can do enough damage for everybody's
ambitions here
quite a while in my opinion and if you
are not a great you know practitioner of
the analytics the paid media
capabilities and most importantly the
create a variable that makes you
successful in these platforms you are
either leaving an enormous amount of
upside on the table or you are starting
the piece you're starting to do the
process that is going to lead to your
demise in any kind of relevance or
growth of your business or ambitions
group chat house party right because
because features are features does
anybody cry when Gucci makes a [ __ ]
cool jacket and then every [ __ ]
fashion house has their version of it
the next day like did anybody notice
that the Yeezys changed every sneaker
spot like this notion that it's bad in
digital but it goes on everywhere in the
world in every category features or
features if you can't beat them join
they're not sure they're not choice
they're not true they're not joining
[ __ ] they're not joining them they're
taking it by recognizing that all the
future frontiers where this plays out
are being built right now so cool you
can't innovate on a feature in a social
network but I don't see you crying that
nobody can innovate and search cuz
Google's been the incumbent now for a
[ __ ] 15 years right maybe what you
should do is realize social might be
gone now and let me go figure out voice
or AR or machine learning or blockchain
there's always a next platform
and let's I mean look we're here I'm not
going anywhere so like but this is
important this is important I don't
understand why we keep doing this we
accept the past we criticize the current
we criticize Facebook for this but
nobody's criticizing Google did the same
thing on search which is why you're not
on the net nobody cried for Yahoo right
so right so so to me this is the
greatness of what Bezos or Zuckerberg
are doing they continue to innovate why
don't we look at the fact that they
continue to innovate right like no you
know nobody got mad at you know NBC for
teaming up with Microsoft to create
MSNBC on cable nobody got mad at like a
real estate tycoon she went out and
bought every good neighborhood for her
30-year run she innovated like let's why
don't we actually look at Google and
other companies like IBM and others and
GE and s AP and why are we why the [ __ ]
was venmo created by two kids and not by
the Royal Bank of Scotland guys we are
looking at this the wrong way we're
we're demonizing people that are doing
without questioning what the incumbents
were doing with all their [ __ ] money
Instagram are driving popular culture
you know what specific areas do you see
is grumpy by mean I mean I mean
Instagram is culture like if you don't
understand that like all of the cultural
plays or plate like if you're not
winning on Instagram from a cool or
culture standpoint whether you're in
hip-hop or eSports or fashion or
anything that we would music anything
that we would say is popular culture you
are losing if you are not winning on
Instagram
you are losing you know what's very and
it's funny it's very
laughing to me I'm fascinating that
people think anything ever stands still
I like when people are like not winning
on its ramp they think they're
maintaining their spot
you are either declining or you are
growing at every second and so my big
fear is that people think well I'm okay
my brain is still doing well I'm still
doing well I'm still doing mmm if you
are not winning on Instagram and you
were in pop culture fashion music
eSports other thing comedy you're in
trouble violent love I'll and I think
it's very much influenced by that
Instagram generation okay nope but it's
it sounds phenomenal desperately
interested they want to have the bikinis
that they're wearing basically people
peril
Elektra Bachelorette meets the Big
Brother house makes sense okay so we
caught them no violent another time but
loved Islands been around for a long
time like like its version of course of
course but but it's been around forever
we love social Experian traffic happens
when there's a car accident you're
[ __ ] nosey like like I think people
this is you know all this stuff the
reason I think I will ultimately have a
good business career is cuz shit's basic
and comes intuitive to me and I've never
complicated it with over educating
myself or thinking I'm fancy shits basic
we love social experiments we like
attractive people like there's not a
whole lot of complicated [ __ ] going on
here right right rapid-fire round and
look anything right now
none what song I remember by t grizzly
the show you're watching none well why
are you drinking
all of them MOT me supporting because I
noticed this is probably the most fun
thing happening in my life right now
which is I want to pick a proper
football team and so Tottenham is the
first jersey I wore because they haven't
because they haven't won in 40 or so
years right my big thing the biggest
debate I'm making now is I'm basically
down to the finals in my head and then
I'll pick the team which is the
following
if they're in the Premier League then
they can't have won in the last 25 years
so who's still in there the bigger
question I want to ask myself is do I
want to go all the way down to the third
League and try to run the whole thing of
the whole process all the way up which
is which is kind of where I think I want
to go Instagram Facebook Facebook uber
lyft uber French Germany or California
learning French Chardonnay I think the
most surprising thing about me my
intuition is the most surprising thing
about me is I don't think people realize
how deeply committed I am to the
propaganda that I spit on pack it for a
second I I get high on my own supply I I
have no interest in letting anybody have
leverage over me so in a world where all
my employees have access to my email my
DMS where d-roc [ __ ] films me and
every [ __ ] move I I have to by virtue
of what I've decided my ambitions are
play a game of life of like you see what
you get at a level that I think is more
extreme I am fascinated by people that
are fans like the Iraq that eventually
get to work very close with me even if
they've consumed me every day for four
years within week one of them working
for me they will inevitably come to me
be like [ __ ] it really is like really
like this huh
so I think I think humans for protection
purposes create a level of cynicism I'm
pushing it so hard and kind of going at
it a certain way
that I have empathy that people create
that but I think the thing that would be
most surprising for I'm so unbelievably
not driven by money yet I have back to
contradictions I am like stunningly not
driven by money but I want to buy a
multi-billion dollar sports organization
I'm I read all of your comments yet I
actually don't give a [ __ ] what you have
to say about me and play within my own
so it's like it's a it's a it's it's
it's so I think the thing you know I
think what do you think Iraq I think you
have a better answer than I have what's
your what's your take what's the most
surprising thing about me
yes what yeah it is what it is like like
I think I'm so obsessed with my legacy
that I and I think that selfish that I
don't think people I don't think most
people 100% live their life based on
their legacy and I'm very close I don't
know if I'm a hundred but like [ __ ] I
really want it I want it I I think and I
think it's selfish and not like I don't
think it's special I just think it's the
way I was wired and so that's what I
think it is break your face I'll take
anyone I can get anywhere do any of you
have any and guys go high or low like go
selfish we're here right what's your
name
No
they won't but they're smart and they're
milking the living [ __ ] there's tons
more Lola nan and there's hundred the
amount of brands that are going from
zero to ten million in sales on
influencers in Facebook and YouTube is
like that's why I sit here and I'm like
this isn't propaganda or what's coming
this is real life I mean you know me
people just play Chinese supply chain
amazon arbitrage and are doing two
million a year like people don't
understand this is my opening rant to
you which is like are you happy cuz if
you're not get educated because there's
a ton of good [ __ ] going on
they won't brother the same way that
Procter & Gamble was built on television
because they understood it best or
Amazon was built on Google AdWords and
they poured a fuckload of money into it
and that's how they became who they are
today I mean literally the company I
think that might be the biggest company
in the world in theory was built on the
back of Google AdWords so they won't if
they're great they'll be able to
understand what's next I think me as a
person will be great because as soon as
I don't like the ROI of Facebook I'll be
super thrilled to have a cartoon version
of me running around all of AR or if I
got to be on the moon or if smoke
signals are back I'll be on the [ __ ]
mountain like wherever the attention is
that that's where I'm gonna be and when
I get there first
it's like real estate I'm gonna not only
get to the beachfront first I'm gonna
build the best hotel the thing that is
really making me when is when I get to
new places I try to bring you value not
me value I made a post on Instagram
yesterday which is like if people gave a
[ __ ] about their audience as much as
they gave a [ __ ] about their audience
giving them a like they'd be in a
totally different place so they won't
you know now if they're really smart
they realize they have to build a brand
not work on the math that they're
trading on now everybody eventually if
they're really great will graduate from
math to art and then respect for both
and so that's how I see it
yes sir both I always say watch what I'm
doing not what I'm saying if I believe
that my website wouldn't be updated I
wouldn't have a text messaging and
messaging bot CRM I implore you if
you're getting value for me eventually
you're gonna realize I only have 13 to
27 beliefs and I'm gonna find a hundred
thousand different ways to say it until
one of the ways at the right moment is
gonna get you to get there the bigger
more interesting reason to continue to
watch me is what am i doing like why did
I build a twitch studio today even if
you even though if you do your homework
I was on justin.tv I love when
everyone's like aw Gary you're late I'm
like [ __ ]
I was playing video games before your
dad thought about your mom you know you
know and so like you know I I I I think
you should do both because what you
don't want to do is be reliant here's
what happens with great platforms they
start off phenomenal and free and they
end up very expensive and not as good
got it
that's the game that's why when you hear
me yelling like I am now about Instagram
influencers in Facebook you know that
this is the time because I know back to
my opening rant even if all of you do it
great it's not gonna come out of me and
what I get in return is your email that
I get 50 times a day which is I did
something nice for you and your life is
different this is the time so I would do
both but to your point real quick
anybody selling [ __ ] back to supernova
Instagram selling hasn't even started
when I think about the sheer amount of
fashion that is gonna be sold through
Instagram when the shop integration is
real seamless and lacks friction this is
why I continue to buy Facebook stock do
you know how much money
Facebook's gonna make when they take a
rack off the top of every transaction
sold of every fashion product sold on
Instagram uh-huh
money go ahead Jenny I saw Jenny do
actually this one I understand pretty
well do I wake up in the morning and
have complete control emotionally and
financially around every single action
I'm about to take that's the best the
best like I do whatever the [ __ ] I want
every day which means there's another
thing people want to look at it one way
you know what else it means it means
everything bad that's happening to you
is on you which makes you feel in
control which makes you happy so I keep
telling everybody I love my losses
they're my else a hundred percent when
you start realizing that brexit or
retaining or [ __ ] Trump or Obama or
Facebook or Instagram don't control you
uh-huh [ __ ] gets real interesting when
you start realizing the answer to
everything is and what and what what do
you tell me you were raped as a kid cool
like it's not cool but and what like
because I'll tell you I know 10 people
that let it get them to a place where
they committed suicide and I'll tell you
10 people who persevered and it became
the strength of their life like my big
thing is if there's a single person that
exists that looks like you from your
circumstance that has ever been happy
and made it well then you can in theory
too and I think we really love excuses
do you know why I pushed so hard against
your series of questions when you opened
if you follow it through it's going to
give people excuses to why not and good
news everybody's gonna ask them no no no
no no no the bigger responsibility is to
actually understand that that's exactly
where everybody's gonna go and the
bigger question becomes when are we
gonna take responsibility on ourselves
24/7 365 for life
because that is a far easier gateway
because guess what I'm thrilled that you
guys are regulating the internet with
all this [ __ ] the blockchain is coming
now what look I think look you have to
know yourself
I love chaos I'd rather do 19 things you
know 7 of them really well 3 shitty one
magically what like that's me other
people really want to go super deep into
one thing I'm not crippled by the
opportunity what I'm trying you know a
lot of the themes we're talking about
we're we're you know it's funny I used
the word accountability I would actually
argue that maybe there's a better word
for energy that I'm trying to deploy
with all these macro things that we're
trying to figure out it's about
self-awareness what's my advice if
you're like me and need all sorts of
stimuli to like live your life it's
probably a good idea to try to challenge
them all like I do if you're somebody
who loves to get like really even go
[ __ ] destroy it on LinkedIn and don't
think about anything else
everybody thinks there's something that
fits all that's just not true it's the
thing that fits you and the big fear
that I have the biggest fear I have
which is why I've been very diligent
about countering my own self speaking to
self awareness is I don't want to make
people like me I'm so petrified that
people see me and want to do me he even
mean the way he's asking this question
has a level of charisma and showmanship
and energy that I'm like okay he
probably can do the blog thing but I
won't like kids like nerdy nerdy nerdy
introverted introverted awkward barely
can even look at me kids come up to me
they're like I'm gonna start a vlog I'm
like uh [ __ ]
like you have to deploy self-awareness
there is so many ways to win this game
to your point maybe you love math so you
should be more dr orient than maybe you
love art you should fall deeply in love
with facebook long-form video because
your one video away from everything
changing so I think it's about
self-awareness brother and I would also
say a lot of people aren't self-aware so
my big thing is it goes back to patience
I don't know try both good mm 19 and 20
is where you go crazy and try to be
great at everything and 20 21 is the
year that you decide after that
whichever one you like the best
you're gonna discipline and go down on
one and I like we have been flow there
your dear Rach we have been flow I think
we're [ __ ] the blue sock right now
on Facebook 15 months ago we were
destroying it like you know like you
know like you and I don't judge myself
like when something like as long as
something's working and it's a net
positive heck if nothing's working it's
kind of interesting to me because I'm
like oh [ __ ] like so I would say that
for two years my podcast was a piece of
[ __ ] then I refigured it came up with
the audio experience and said askgaryvee
and it went right Instagram was I wasn't
doing my thing then I decided to get
serious and it started becoming a thing
YouTube this then did it did it did it
it got it and you have to know why
you're doing things let me explain d-roc
is devastated that our YouTube isn't
better you know daily be is probably
declined in viewership not grown in the
last year I'm pumped because the
singular reason I'm doing daily B is to
put all this [ __ ] on the record you know
do you know fun
this video is to watch in 29 years
do you know fun it is for me to call her
and be like yo you were super right
about this how about me on that one but
you know what I mean like look you know
after living what I lived from 95 to
2007 I was like [ __ ] I was right about a
lot of [ __ ] you know and like and also a
lot of cool things like you know cooler
would have been to have the video of me
speaking to Facebook back in the day
when the whole company was 300 people
that's just fun for my kids that's just
fun for me like you know how people like
looking at pictures how about having 38
minutes of your every day of your every
there's a lot of other reasons to do a
vlog that have nothing to do with more
visitors to our businesses your great
great grandkids are gonna watch it and
I'd like oh I have his nose you know
like it's [ __ ] cool like this is
special
well of course but guess what if it's
your grandmother you want that noise got
it like for you you want it like if I
told you right now hey weird I've got a
vlog of your grandmother when she was
from 20 to 30
every minute you're watching every
[ __ ] second I may not watch every
second of your grandma but you are right
and so you do certain things for
different reasons I've got a whole
nother thing I put my IP me as a human
into a trust with no value attached to
it for my kids I think it's gonna be the
biggest financial thing I leave them I
believe that in 53 years there's
somebody actually sitting in that couch
right now during this exact session
feels like they're here right now with
us sitting right there with the
advancement of VR and they paid my
family's trust 800 bucks to be sitting
there 15 years and it's called life
logging and his reason for doing that is
he can then call up say like what was
that line I had in that on that holiday
in Sicily who's got this screen and the
reason that they're creating all of
these memories is so that they can
eventually use them for human beings you
know we're living much longer and and if
you happen for example I have
Alzheimer's it can be a way of actually
trying to reconfigure your brain so that
you can actually tap into those memories
so there is so much potential of where
this could go I have every word that
I've spoken on every video of every one
of these vlogs for the last three years
transcribed and searchable you want to
know what my thoughts on snapchat have
been for the last four and a half years
straight
here you go I mean it's it's and people
think of it as like being a charlatan or
self-absorbed like people are short-term
thinkers I'm playing chess out here
and I think people playing checkers yeah
no champ James Gary a nice Amiga I'm
marking direct to the fostering agency I
be H it for nine years business and
fashion events got an opportunity
November to join the fostering world
looked at the industry knew I was going
to revolutionize it and got to a point
now where an impact is greater than what
I ever imagined our recently did
analysis on our video campaign compared
to our six competitors or great videos
and we combined we smash them by an
additional 25% so I've got one of our
directors visit next week and I'm gonna
be telling him that we need to build the
team to capitalize on that so what
advice would you suggest in terms of
building that that team you go with
experience over of youth or both
so master mix of both I'm a you know how
in fashion a decade ago it became
obvious that it was gonna be about
high-low right like especially in the
women's sector I thought it was so
interesting to watch like it was cool to
have a $5,000 purse and $3 sandals and
$9 top and $300 jeans and I thought that
was so great and I think that's now
actually how society itself is period
that's how I think about production I
think what we're learning at Manor we
think about this we're starting to get
our foot foot our hands around they'd
probably fee to around this high low I
think you know you get a producer who
has 16 years of experience she could be
a badass and can help you a ton but you
get somebody who knows how to film on a
camera or their phone and they're 22 and
they can afford to like really do it for
less clearly than somebody who's been
doing it for 16 years I'm very hot on
production capabilities being high low
because the problem with high is not
only cost but it's also entitlement the
the reason I'm calling my next sneaker
clouds and dirt is my magic is being in
the dirt I don't think I'm too fancy to
community managed to you or answer your
DM or post my own copy or do any of this
[ __ ] and a second you give up the dirt
you become vulnerable
consummate good
the same emotional yes
I deploy a motion good emotion to
everybody else but I don't I look I
think for me I still believe in no
motion meaning I do not make decisions
out of defense and I think when you're
going with emotion you know I have
empathy and compassion and I think it's
super important to bring more but the
ultimate leverage in life is giving
somebody more than you're asking for in
return so I like doing that I just want
to give that I want I did it for my own
parents like real quick just so you you
know I always say like if you're smart
you can really figure [ __ ] out the fact
that I need I needed forget about being
a good boy I needed for me because I was
so grateful for my folks to go into
their business and completely change the
course of their game not for me for them
I needed to settle the score with my
parents of course I want to bring value
to my community got it so look I think I
think when you have a business you're an
employee right you have a different game
but as the number one you have to
understand it's all in your it's all on
you it was if something bad happened
it's on you if a client fires us well I
could have done a better job I could
have staffed it better I could have
checked in more on the decision maker a
million things could have and so I don't
I don't worry about what outside forces
are doing to me because when you start
dwelling you start looking in the wrong
direction
so I try to be like I you know I may get
up I mean you get upset you have to
understand the difference between a
macro and a micro analyzation of caring
and got it I think you have to know your
environment being vulnerable at
vaynermedia is super easy being
vulnerable at some other company not as
easy I mean you got to know the room
you're in right the context I think you
know so I mean ultimately this got
brought up again earlier and I'm really
happy it did I love when people like
you're confusing me or this or your or
your conflicting yourself I'm like of
course because in the in
most basic statements I think of all of
it like a bridge there are so many
forces pulling and in that is the
strength like I'm awfully emotional and
I'm completely unemotional now to go
decipher that in a [ __ ] Instagram
post like you know what I mean like it's
the context to all of this that matters
here's what I would say I and look I'm
probably reacting to my father my father
mainly made emotional decisions at the
heat of visit upsetness was when he
decided to make a business move
not my for me of course I get upset
listen bro you know this like there's
88,000 things wrong with vaynermedia
probably you know like I could sit and
dwell on that or I could think about the
many things that are going well and
continue the process of trying to fix
the ones that aren't going well so for
me this is just super [ __ ] binary the
whole theme of if you know for the
people at home they're gonna watch us on
YouTube if you really take a step back
after a couple glasses of wine if you
watch this today's talk where this talk
was and this is think thank you so much
and the energy of you guys this is a
very clear mapping of where I'm at which
is this shit's binary either you see it
good or you see it bad either you see
offense or you see defense this is one
or zero
it's truly that and I think everything
we're doing over complicates it over
complicates it and you're not looking at
the actual game and so yeah both but I
never make decisions out of a place of
weakness which is usually when you're
most emotional about something that you
don't control right by virtue client
services suck because you're not in
control because one client can fire you
and really change the trajectory of a
business which is why veiners been
always so healthy because I never let
any client get too big of a percentage
of our business because I don't want to
be at the mercy of anything or anybody
ever ever deep mention voice AI area
it would be remiss of me not to ask you
a question
but I'm just thinking about all of the
people in the room Gary earlier to tweet
it retweeted an article that I have
written about our conversation voice the
I so you can get a lot more on that we
won't get into great depth but this is
something you're extremely excited about
and you know as someone who's working in
the publishing world I'm wondering yeah
Boise on something that everyone wants
to think we're grabbing on so now should
we be innovating and I can't find a
business case for it now you know what
would you say to people who are really
interested in this but aren't sure about
whether they should invest the money or
the time or the effort in it because
it's kind of a road map that hasn't
really been laid out just yet go read
the history of the iPhone in the first
year yes yeah real quick I want to bring
you guys some value on the iPhone just
to like back to remember when I said I
gotta add sentences like cool mic drop
iPhone but let me tell you why I want to
remind you this is the place where
Spotify and Instagram and ways and many
others built multi-billion dollar cup
like you know some of them looking
around a lot of us were here when the
iPhone came right goober and a listen we
could sit here I mean like so like every
gaming company Roby I mean like
multi-billion dollar companies built
exclusively through being something on
top of this I believe that the voice
devices in whatever manifestation
there'll be speakers now later they'll
be in our walls or whatever it may be
that the apps built on top of them will
be some of the biggest companies in the
world because you will use those apps
because of the lack of friction the same
reason you you the reason you use Waze
is because it's better than the gremlin
[ __ ] we used to have in our car which
was better than the [ __ ] map that we
used to pull out it's better and voice
is gonna be better in the same way that
you guys everything goes in circles you
now text a lot where you used to talk
now Boise is going to come along and
take a lot of your texting away because
you're going to be in your office and
like tell my wife I'll be home in seven
minutes and that'll be it
not let me grab my phone let me text my
find my wife's contact I'll be home in
seven minutes
it's just faster and you will choose
speed every day of your life oh [ __ ] I'm
right here dude let's go laughing [ __ ]
I'm a little scared now
do you rock if I lose take it out okay
see those guns I do see them honey
should somebody go 1 2 3 1 2 3 thank you
so much for such a great job don't worry
let's clap it up she was phenomenal
[Applause]
the arm wrestling thing is gonna be so
long
[Music]